wir kommen damit zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
ist seit dem jahr 2000 wird hier die eeg
umlage erhoben
und angesichts der verschiedenen
entlastungspaket für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher die auf
grund der hohen inflation der
gestiegenen energiepreise
nun doch deutlich mehr geld ausgeben
müssen hat sich die ampel koalition
entschieden diese eeg-umlage
abzusinken
und zwar auf 0 schon zum ersten juli
ursprünglich wollte man das er später
machen
aber das soll jetzt kommen und oliver
krischer der zuständige parlamentarische
staatssekretär äußert sich als erstes
dazu die umlage ist jahrelang einer der
größten strom preisbestandteile gewesen
6,5 cent pro kilowattstunde noch im
letzten jahr und wir entscheiden jetzt
diese umlage in zukunft nicht mehr zu
erheben meine damen und herren das ist
für die menschen im land die größte
strompreis entlastung der letzten
jahrzehnte und die richtige antwort vor
dem hintergrund der gestiegenen durch
fossile energie gestiegenen
energiepreise die ampel schafft den
entscheidenden schritt zur senkung der
strompreise an dem sämtliche vorherigen
bundesregierung gescheitert sind
aber die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
entlastet nicht nur den strompreis
sondern sie schafft auch
wettbewerbsgleichheit zwischen
erneuerbaren energien und fossilen
energien und so ermöglichen wir das
erneuerbarer strom im wärme und
verkehrssektor
konkurrenzfähig wird dass wir mit
wärmepumpen und elektromobilität die
transformation hin zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft schaffen das
ist ganz entscheidend um das land
klimaneutral zu machen die senkung die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage ist hierzu
ein ganz entscheidender baustein
und darüber hinaus geht es darum dass
die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
gleichzeitig aber auch ein
bürokratieabbau programm ist denn wo es
erhebungs bürokratie ausnahme bürokratie
gab da sind schlupflöcher gesucht worden
und das schaffen wir ab das ist eines
der größten im energiebereich größten
bürokratieabbau programme dass diese
umlage nicht mehr erhoben wird meine
damen und herren und ganz nebenbei
führt das auch noch dazu dass eines der
haupthindernisse für miete strom und
eigenen stromerzeugung im erneuerbaren
bereich abgeschafft wird meine damen und
herren das ist ein großer erfolg dieser
bundesregierung
und ich möchte an dieser stelle eines
erwähnen ziemlich genau vor zehn jahren
hat hier peter altmaier eine
strompreis bremse verkündet diejenigen
kolleginnen und kollegen die ein
bisschen länger dabei sind können sich
vielleicht daran erinnern seine politik
und die nachfragen der bundesregierung
hat nicht dazu geführt dass der
strompreis gebremst wurde gebremst wurde
nur der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
und das hat uns in eine fatale
abhängigkeit von fossilen
energieimporten gebracht die uns jetzt
bitter bitter beschäftigt meine damen
und herren die andere koalition stellt
diese fatale politik jetzt vom kopf
wieder auf die füße wir beenden die
fossilen abhängigkeit durch den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien und entlasten
damit menschen und wirtschaft in diesem
land dankeschön
und ich hatte das wort dem kollegen mark
helfrich cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die preise steigen die
inflationsrate ist in deutschland so
hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr
ebenso die erzeugerpreise verbraucher
müssen sie doch weitere hohe
preissteigerungen einstellen und das
nicht nur bei strom heizöl und gas viele
menschen und unternehmen kommen schon
jetzt nicht mehr mit den hohen preisen
zu recht deshalb ist die abschaffung der
eeg umlage zur mitte des jahres
alternativlos wir als union hatten die
vollständige abschaffung der eeg umlage
als priorität bereits in unserem
wahlprogramm folgerichtig haben wir die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage bereits mitte
februar von ihnen gefordert und deshalb
dürfte es auch keine allzu große
überraschung sein dass wir dem gesetz
der ampel zustimmen werden
unser gemeinsames ziel ist es dass die
mit dem wegfall der eeg-umlage entstehen
entlastung auch beim verbraucher ankommt
im gesetz ist hier eine verpflichtung
der stromlieferanten zur absenkung des
strompreises in höhe der wegfallenden
eeg-umlage vorgesehen diese
verpflichtung sehen wir kritisch warum
zum einen bedeutet sie einen erheblichen
eingriff in die vertragsfreiheit der
unternehmen
aber zum anderen erweist die ampel damit
dem verbraucher auch einen bärendienst
die regelung verhindert nämlich
keinesfalls der stromlieferanten
betriebswirtschaftlich notwendige
preiserhöhung auf den ersten juni
vorziehen am ende zahlen die verbraucher
sogar noch einen monat früher höhere
preise und deshalb an die ampel gut
gemeint ist nicht gut gemacht
sehr geehrte damen und herren
die abschaffung der eeg-umlage kann nur
ein erster schritt zur entlastung der
privaten haushalte und der wirtschaft
sein viele sind bereits aufgrund der
hohen energiepreise in existenzielle
schwierigkeiten geraten die ampel hat
hier entlastungen für die bürger und
hilfen für die wirtschaft angekündigt
das klingt erst einmal ganz gut schaut
man sich das entlastungspaket für die
bürger einmal genauer an so tut sich bei
der angekündigten energie pauschale ein
großes fragezeichen auf genauer gesagt
etwa 22 millionen fragezeichen so viele
rentner und pensionäre gibt es nämlich
in deutschland sie alle werden die
energie pauschale nach den plänen der
ampel regierung nicht erhalten ein
viertel der bevölkerung deutschlands
wird einfach mal hinten runter gekippt
das darf nicht sein
ebenso darf nicht sein dass die ampel
unentwegt von der 300 euro energie
pauschale spricht und sich davon aber
durch die versteuerung im durchschnitt
wieder 100 euro in die eigene tasche
steckt das ist schlicht und ergreifend
eine mogelpackung
von der gleichen großzügigkeit im
auslassen ist auch das hilfspaket für
die wirtschaft gekennzeichnet vom
energie zuschuss auf denen die
wirtschaft zu dringend gewartet hat
profitiert nur die großindustrie aus
energie und handelns intensiven branche
unser mittelstand der rückgrat der
deutschen wirtschaft bleibt außen vor
große teile der wirtschaft das handwerk
die familienunternehmen bekommen keinen
energie zu schluss auch sie werden
einfach hinten runter gekippt an dieser
stelle sage ich ihnen von der ampel
eines ganz deutlich die bürger erwarten
mehr von ihnen die wirtschaft erwartet
mehr von ihnen wir erwarten mehr von
ihnen keine mogelpackung mehr
berücksichtigen sie die 22 millionen
rentner und pensionäre bei der energie
pauschale berücksichtigen sie unseren
mittelstand bei energie zuschuss und
lassen sie keine bereiche der wirtschaft
aus und
kommen sie mir jetzt bitte nicht mit dem
argument der hohen kosten die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage kostet die
ampel keine 6,6 milliarden euro wie sie
uns weismachen wollen im gegenteil sie
müssen keinen einzigen cent ausgeben auf
dem eeg konto haben sie nicht sich
nämlich per märz dieses jahres bereits
14,6 milliarden euro angehäuft wegen der
hohen strompreise wird das eg konto am
ende des jahres sogar mit einem
zweistelligen milliarden euro betrag
plus sein und das trotz dieses gesetzes
wenn die ampel also diese milliarden die
den verbrauchern über ihre stromrechnung
abgeknöpft worden schon nicht
zurückzahlen will dann fordern wir sie
auf senken sie die stromsteuer auf den
europäischen mindeststeuersatz und
senken sie die umsatzsteuer auf strom
gas und fernwärme für dieses und
nächstes jahr auf 7 prozent länder
länder wie italien spanien die
niederlande österreich polen und belgien
haben hier bereits vorgelegt um bürger
und wirtschaft umfassen zu entlasten
beides wäre schnell umsetzbar und zwar
das ohne dass irgendjemand einfach
hinten runter gekippt wird
und der nächste redner in der debatte
andreas mehr tretter spd fraktion
andreas mehltretter sitzt im ausschuss
für klimaschutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren mit dem kurs auf eine
energiewende haben wir schon lange die
weichen in die richtige richtung
gestellt wir brauchen die energiewende
weil wir den klimawandel begrenzen
müssen wir brauchen die energiewende
weil sie uns unabhängig von fossilen
energieträgern macht und wir brauchen
die energiewende weil schon heute die
erneuerbaren die günstigste form der
stromerzeugung sind die richtung stimmt
aber die geschwindigkeit hat bisher
nicht gepasst gut dass mit der neuen
regierung jetzt die energiewende fahrt
aufnimmt
mit dem so genannten ostertag jetzt
bringen wir eine große beschleunigungs
novelle des erneuerbare energien
gesetzes auf den weg schon in zehn
jahren wird der strom in deutschland
größtenteils aus erneuerbaren energien
stammen saubere sichere und bezahlbare
energie dafür sind wir angetreten das
werden wir auch erreichen
meine damen und herren die absenkung der
eeg umlage auf 0 hatten wir schon im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart die
absenkung ist wichtig weil dadurch weil
wir dadurch den umstieg auf strom gerade
im wärme und verkehrssektor erleichtern
und weil wir strom einfach und effizient
erneuerbar herstellen können
beschleunigen wir damit die energiewende
entscheidend
gleichzeitig darf aber eine
beschleunigte energiewende niemanden
überfordern wir wollen preiseffekte als
lenkung instrumente einsetzen wir
schaffen aber auch einen sozialen
ausgleich wo es notwendig ist auch dafür
ist die absenkung der eeg umlage das
richtige instrument weil sie eben sozial
gerecht wird haushalte mit geringerem
einkommen geben anteilsmäßig viel mehr
für strom aus als haushalte mit hohem
einkommen die absenkung der eeg umlage
auf null entlastet gerade die haushalte
die sich teure energie nicht leisten
können deswegen ist es sinnvoll die
energiewende über den bundeshaushalt und
nicht über die stromrechnung zu
finanzieren meine damen und herren
bereits im letzten jahr mussten wir
gerade beim gas einen massiven
preisanstieg beobachten der angriff gut
dienst auf die ukraine hat die
energiepreise weiter steigen lassen und
der hohen gaspreis schlägt sich über die
damit sehr teuren gaskraftwerke auch im
stromkreis meter wir brauchen jetzt
wirksame entlastungen für die privaten
haushalte und für unsere unternehmen
deshalb haben wir ja zwei große
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
und deswegen ziehen wir die absenkung
der eeg umlage vor
zum ersten juli sinken die strompreise
um 3,7 cent je kilowattstunde inklusive
mehrwertsteuer sind es sogar 4,4 sind so
entlasten wir haushalte und betriebe
schnell und zuverlässig um sechs
milliarden euro in diesem jahr 130 euro
spart eine familie mit 4000
kilowattstunden jahresverbrauch in der
zweiten jahreshälfte durch die absenkung
der eeg umlage im vergleich zu 20 21
wichtig ist dass die absenkung auch
direkt bei die stromverbraucher die
jüngste und verbrauchern ankommt
deswegen kann geht im gesetz vorgesehen
dass die stromversorger diese
preissenkung zum ersten juli zwingend
weitergeben müssen mit einer ergänzung
der regelung schärfen wir außerdem dort
nach wo sachverständige in der anhörung
noch eine lücke aufgezeigt haben meine
damen und herren
klimawandel steigende preise die
abhängigkeit von rohstoffimporten aus
russland und anderen autokratien wir
brauchen eine schnelle energiewende und
wir brauchen schnelle und wirksame
entlastungen ein baustein zu beiden
energiewende und entlastungen leisten
wir heute mit der absenkung der eeg
umlage auf null
die fdp fraktion hat hier auch ein
entschließungsantrag
vorgelegt zu diesem gesetzentwurf und
dazu äußern und diesen erläutern kann
nun mag bernhard aus der afg fraktion
er ist der baupolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
letzte woche ist meine nachbarin
freudestrahlend auf mich zugekommen sie
hat einen brief von ihrem
energieversorger in der hand der ihm
mitgeteilt hat dass sie ab ersten juli
nicht mehr 33 cent je kilowattstunde
zahlen muss sondern nur noch 27
überrascht hat sie mich gefragt und die
eeg-umlage tatsächlich ab juli wegfallen
würde ich habe dann geantwortet ja bei
der stromrechnung schon das hat sich
aber dann doch aufhorchen lassen und ich
musste ihr erklären richtig ist dass die
eeg zahlung nicht weg fällt sondern
künftig nur anders finanziert wird
nämlich nicht mehr direkt über ihre
stromrechnung sondern über steuern und
abgaben auf energie
also immer dann wenn sie brot beim
bäcker kauft im supermarkt ihre einkäufe
erledigt oder dienstleistungen beim
handwerker bestellt was hier was wir
hier von der regierung präsentiert
bekommen ist also nichts anderes als
eine mogelpackung die eine entlastung
suggerieren soll aber in der realität
nichts aber auch gar nichts einen
energiekosten ändert und warum haben wir
in deutschland trotz ihres
taschenspielertricks immer noch die
höchsten strompreise der welt weil
selbst nach aussage des
wirtschaftsministeriums windenergie nur
zu fünf prozent immer sicher zur
verfügung steht das bedeutet dass sie
eben zu 95 prozent nicht sicher zur
verfügung steht und wir deshalb jeden
eben jede windindustrie anlage ein
konventionelles kraftwerk mit der
gleichen leistung stellen müssen damit
es nicht eben nicht ausgeht wenn gerade
mal kein wind weht
so haben wir so haben wir im sommer
mittags meistens zu viel viel zu viel
strom im netz und müssen deshalb unsere
nachbarländer bitten uns diesen strom
abzunehmen und ihnen dafür auch noch
viele hunderte von millionen euro
bezahlen damit unser stromnetz nicht
zusammenbricht werden wir dann in der
nacht wenn gerade kein wind wie strom zu
exorbitant teuren preisen aus dem
ausland importieren müssen und dieser
irrsinn führt dazu dass wir in
deutschland doppelt so hohe strompreise
haben wie in unseren nachbarländern
warum wie und wieso zahlen die auch
sonst nur die hälfte ganz einfach sie
setzen auf kernenergie
belgien verlängert die laufzeiten seiner
kernkraftwerke um zehn jahre england boe
sechs neue frankreich schweden holland
tschechien setzen so wie so oft
kernenergie und erzeugen damit günstigen
strom und sind vor allem von russischen
energie importen unabhängig
außerdem entlasten sie ihre bürger durch
massive steuersenkungen so senkt holland
die mehrwertsteuer auf energie von 21
auf 9 prozent belgien von 21 auf 6
prozent und in griechenland zahlt der
staat sogar ein drittel der
stromrechnung und was macht die
regierung in deutschland
taschenspielertricks uns gar nichts
dabei wäre es doch ein
nicht so einfach allein durch die
laufzeitverlängerung unser 3 noch
aktiven kernkraftwerke und die
reaktivierung der drei kürzlich
heruntergefahrenen könnten wir sicheren
und preiswerten strom erzeugen und damit
die kompletten kohle importe aus
russland innerhalb kürzester zeit
ersetzen wir müssen es machen wie unsere
europäischen
nachbarn die steuern auf energie senken
mehrwertsteuer auf null und co2 steuer
abschaffen herzlichen dank
marc bernhard aus der fdp fraktion war
das und er hat es eben auch angedeutet
unter anderem fordert die fraktion im
entschließungsantrag alle zahlungen und
begünstigung nach dem erneuerbaren
energien gesetz ersatzlos zu streichen
auf ihn folgten konrad stockmeier für
die fdp-fraktion
und kollegen es ist toll dass es die
bundestags mediathek gibt gucken sie
sich mal meine letzte rede an und dann
sind die ausführungen zur kernenergie
diese getätigt haben abgefrühstückt
sich
heute fast der deutsche bundestag einen
beschluss auf denen die freien
demokraten seit jahren in der
energiepolitik hin jetzt seien sie doch
mal ruhig es ist ja unerträglich
auf wenige freien demokraten seit jahren
hingearbeitet haben die vollständige
entlastung der unternehmen und
verbraucher von der eeg-umlage endlich
ist es soweit
diese entlastung ist angesichts der
hohen energiepreise zweifellos geboten
sie kommt jetzt auch unternehmen zugute
die nicht zu den stromintensiven zählen
und die bisher deswegen auch nicht durch
die besondere ausgleichsregelung bei der
zahlung der eeg-umlage begünstigt wurden
jetzt ist es endlich soweit mit dieser
absenkung der eeg umlage auf null werden
aber auch einige
konstruktionsfehler in der eeg-umlage
endgültig beseitigt energiepolitisch
systematische konstruktionsfehler
erstens beispielhaft möchte ich nennen
das die klimapolitischen potenziale der
sektor kopplung jetzt endlich besser
genutzt werden können denn wer will dass
mehr grüner strom in verkehr und in
gebäuden genutzt wird und das sind
entsprechende technologien investiert
wird der muss diesen grünen strom eben
auch billiger macht
zweitens war es von anfang an gesagt
zweitens war es von anfang an fragt
würde ich das
gesamtgesellschaftlich gewünschte
energie und klimapolitische maßnahmen
quasi nur von den stromverbrauchern zu
tragen waren deswegen also deswegen ist
es auch gut dass dieser
konstruktionsfehler jetzt beseitigt wird
und über verteilungswirkungen ja es hat
keinen sinn mit ihnen darüber zu reden
da dürfte die einsicht begrenzt sein
stellt sich ein bisschen komplexer dar
als sie das dargestellt haben also wird
jetzt dieser gravierende
verteilungspolitische
konstruktionsfehler der eeg umlage auch
endlich beseitigt und wir gehen damit
zumindest einen wichtigen schritt in
richtung der beseitigung von
inkonsistenzen in dieser ständigen
parallelen anwendung von mehreren
förderinstrumenten umlage hier abgabe
der besteuerung dort förderung was weiß
ich wo an der stelle will ich noch
einmal betonen dass wir freien
demokraten uns seit langen dafür
einsetzen dass der handel mit
emissionszertifikaten für treibhausgase
wirklich das zentrale steuerungselement
der energiewende wird und zwar auch so
dass eben nicht ständig andere maßnahmen
dar ein funken dieses ziel ist mit dem
heutigen schritt zugegebenermaßen noch
nicht vollständig erreicht aber wir
gehen einen wichtigen schritt in die
richtige richtung
und damit die heute zu beschließenden
entlastung tatsächlich auch bei den
privathaushalten und bei den
verbrauchern wirklich transparent
ankommt sichern wir auch ab dass das
durch entsprechende änderungen im
energiewirtschaftsgesetz passiert
und was bietet jetzt sozusagen der blick
in die zukunft
der blick in die zukunft bietet dass wir
bei der energieversorgung mit
erneuerbaren energien wirklich auf
freiheitliche zeiten zu steuern in denen
wir abhängigkeiten abbauen können und da
lohnt sich wirklich auch der blick in
wissenschaftliche magazine der austausch
mit forschern und auch mit unternehmen
deutsche forscher entwickeln zurzeit
tandem solarzellen mit ungekannten
wirkungsgraden es werden neue formen der
brennstoffzellen in kombination mit ganz
spannenden speichertechnologien
entwickelt das repowering bei wasser-
und windkraft verspricht auch große
potenziale
das heißt die erneuerbaren energien
werden immer weiter konkurrenzfähig
werden und wenn wir bei der kreativität
wenn wir der kreativität bei
speichertechnologien und auch digitaler
steuerung des ganzen stromnetzes und des
verbrauchers mehr raum entfalten dann
achtung zu hause in mannheim würde man
sagen auf masse und das werden sie ewig
bestreiten und vielleicht werden sie es
irgendwann zur kenntnis nehmen dann
werden nämlich die erneuerbaren energien
auch grundlastfähig werden in diesem
sinne
zwischen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
klaus ernst fraktion die linke ist der
nächste redner
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
wie die lage ist das sagen wir uns immer
wieder die preise sind extrem hoch heute
75 prozent 3 steigerungsraten bekannt
gegeben immer mehr überlegen sich wie
sie das noch zahlen sollen und wir haben
keine lösung
die strompreise sind zum großen teil
staatlich verursachte auch das wissen
wir und insofern ist es natürlich
vollkommen richtig dass die
bundesregierung jetzt maßnahmen
vorschlägt mit denen der strompreis
durch die absenkung der oder abschaffung
der eeg-umlage erstmal erst mal weg ist
und damit eine entlastung stattfindet ob
das tatsächlich auch zu einer senkung
der strompreise ist für mich natürlich
eine andere frage weil weitere andere
maßnahmen den strompreis natürlich
weiter erhöhen werden
das maßnahmenpaket das die
bundesregierung sonst so beschlossen hat
ist auch nett aber jeder der da braucht
man kein mathematik professor sein dann
weiß man dass die sieben und vor die
nicht ausreicht dass man das ausgleicht
was durch diese enormen
preissteigerungsraten verursacht und
dann sind die preissteigerungsraten
natürlich kriegsbedingt auch das ist
klar aber nicht nur kriegsbedingt sie
sind natürlich auch sanktions bedingt
nicht alle dieser preissteigerung
genommen haben sind unmittelbar auf den
krieg sondern viele sind darauf
zurückzuführen wie wir auf diesen kriege
reagieren und mir kommt es manchmal so
vor dass ich sage mir passt es nicht
dass putin macht und deswegen habe ich
mir selber eine rein
und es ist nicht gerade das ist nicht
gerade eine vernünftige politik meine
damen und herren und sie wissen auch
ganz genau das war auf dauer
es nicht schaffen werden auch nicht als
reiche bundesrepublik deutschland durch
staatliche maßnahmen das auszugleichen
was auf wirtschaftlicher ebene auch
durch die preise dem bürger zugemutet
wird ich sollte es geht übrigens heute
die cdu darauf hingewiesen in einer rede
die ich gehört habe vollkommen richtig
aber wo sie brüstet dann die lösung
also
bitte märz also da kann ich nur sagen
der sorgt auf der einen seite wieder so
100 milliarden ausgeben für rüstung und
sorgte auf der anderen seite zum kannst
du hälst die schuldenbremse nicht ein
also irgendwo mal seit einigen wochen
bietet natürlich geht beides nicht weiß
jeder da kann man noch so ruppig
jonglieren wie mit der fdp vorsitzende
als finanz schon gehört da könnte im
zirkus auftreten mit seiner nummer aber
das ist
wilder sagen wenn uns das nicht gelingt
über staatliche maßnahme dann nicht mehr
vergleichbar darüber nachdenken dass wir
nicht 100 milliarden mal da für rüstung
ausgeben tote piraten für extra programm
wenn wir gleichzeitig wissen dass das
geld fehlt dann kommen eben da muss man
eben mehr maßnahmen daraus wirklich
verwenden zu überlegen wie kommen dem
krieg durch diplomatische mittel
tatsächlich beenden wenn wir dies weiter
so machen wie das großvorhaben durch
weitere rüstung dank gefährden wir nicht
nur die bürger durch drei
steigerungsraten sondern wir wissen dass
mit jeder maßnahme die zur zeit
eskaliert wir an denen einem atomkrieg
ein stück näher kommen meine damen und
herren und ich hoffe dass es uns gelingt
dass wir wieder einen weg finden aus
dieser spirale herauszukommen wenn wir
so weitermachen dann werden wir uns nur
für drei steigerungsraten überlegen
sondern unser land vielleicht auch unser
land wieder aufbauen müssen und in der
ukraine
soweit der vorsitzenden des ausschusses
für klimaschutz und energie und die
nächste rednerin ist da auch mitglied
kathrin bühlig für bündnis 90 die grünen
im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren vor einigen
tagen sprach mich eine ältere dame an ob
ich ihr sagen könnte wie es mit den
energiepreisen weitergeht ihre rente
wäre so knapp obwohl sie ihrem
sechzehnten lebensjahr immer gearbeitet
hätte bereits die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise
während für sie schwierig die miete wäre
zum glück noch bezahlbar weil sie schon
so lange dort wohnt aber jetzt hätte sie
gehört dass auch strom und gas teurer
werden würden
ähnlich wird es sicherlich studierenden
auszubildenden gehen und allen menschen
die sehr genau auf ihre ausgaben achten
müssen denn die energiepreise sind
aufgrund der fossilen energieträger
aktuell sehr hoch und viele menschen
wissen noch nicht wie ihre rechnungen
für strom und gas aussehen werden
aber nicht nur auf den rechnungen sind
die fossilen energieträger teuer
auch der aktuelle bericht des
weltklimarates sagt deutlich wir müssen
raus aus den fossilen energien
wenn wir die klimakrise ihre folgen und
auch ihre kosten noch auf ein
erträgliches maß begrenzen wollen wir
müssen jetzt ambitioniert handeln wenn
wir hitzesommer und trockene böden
starkregen ereignisse und wirbelstürme
und die damit verbundenen folgen nicht
noch weiter verstärken wollen
und als wäre das nicht schon genug
werden wir aktuell jeden tag im
angesicht des schrecklichen
angriffskrieges daran erinnert wie sehr
wir uns von fossilen importen abhängig
gemacht haben weil wir nicht noch
schneller alternativen bereit stellen
können so sehr wir uns das auch wünschen
würden
wir brauchen endlich eine zeitenwende
auch in der energiepolitik die
ökologische und soziale aspekte
berücksichtigt durch die entscheidungen
der letzten jahre wurde der notwendige
ökologische wandel verzögert und damit
auch die sozialen auswirkungen bewusst
in kauf genommen es ist mehr als
überfällig dass wir nun endlich handeln
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf und
den ergänzungen im verfahren stellen wir
sicher dass die absenkung der eeg umlage
auf null
als entlastung auch wirklich bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt das kann
aber nur ein erster schritt sein
das nun vom kabinett beschlossene oster
paket stellt die weichen für mehr
erneuerbare energien und den
energiemarkt der zukunft für bezahlbare
preise und für energie souveränität wir
müssen diesen wandel aktiv und
ambitioniert gestalten ökologisch für
das klima und sozial für die menschen
damit schaffen wir sicherheit für alle
menschen und zeigen was freiheit nr gen
wirklich können
herzlichen dank
kathrin ullrich war das hier in der
debatte über die absenkung der
kostenbelastung durch die eeg-umlage ein
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt von den
fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die grünen und
fdp und nina scheer spricht jetzt für
die sozialdemokraten
ich möchte noch mal kurz ein bisschen
ausholen weil es noch nicht erläutert
wurde in der heutigen debatte woher wir
eigentlich mit dem erneuerbaren energien
gesetz kommen denn zu anfang war einfach
die überlegung wie kriegt man ein system
etabliert zur markteinführung
erneuerbare energien die sich
vorgefunden haben in einem markt der
hochsubventioniert fossil atomaren prägt
war und durch diese hohen subventionen
ist auch keine
eintrittspforte für andere energieformen
gab
nach den prinzipien des marktes dort
eintritt erhalten insofern war die
überzeugung dass man gesetzliches
regulativ finden muss damit diese
ungleiche markt 1 ausgleich hat und man
quasi einen markteintritt für die am 11
und damit man keine abhängigkeit vom
haushaltsgesetzgeber dabei hat war es
eben die idee dies über eine umlage auf
alle stromkunden zu finanzieren wenn man
aus der perspektive einer
markteinführung sich das betrachtet und
auch überlegt das damals keinerlei
ausnahmeregelung existierten die dann
über die letzten jahre hinzubekommen
sind die dann alle auf die stromkunden
umgelegt wurden die nicht unter die
ausnahmeregelung fehlt also die keine
entlastung hat durch die sogenannte
besondere ausgleichsregelung dann weiß
man auch dass natürlich die belastung
der stromkunden durch diese eeg-umlage
am anfang sehr gering war und im
verhältnis zu den enormen unterstützungs
effekten im ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wirklich vernachlässigung sphe
ich war allerdings dank durch die
einführung der besonderen
ausgleichsregelung
wurde eine schieflage geschaffen weil
all die entlastungen die dann in der die
intensive unternehmen bekamen allein
durch die privatkunden gezahlt wurden
übernommen wurden das wurde immer mehr
und mehr und mehr da hätte man schon als
gesetzgeber sagen kann ok vielleicht
wäre das auch eine möglichkeit diese
entlastungen die ihrem sinn hatten nicht
die strom bezahlen zu lassen sondern
staatlich auf die steuersenkungen zu
finanzieren
ebenso hätte man das hatten wir auch
2013 mal diskutiert auch während der
koalitionsverhandlung 2013 diskutiert
wie wäre es denn wenn die die ganzen
innovations- anteile wieder anstecken
weil ja die erneuerbaren energien eine
enorme land kurve hingelegt haben in den
ersten jahren sehr teuer waren die am
anfang der fonds über billige hat durch
die macht an das war ja quasi ein
industrialisierungsprozess das hätte man
auch herausschneiden können aus der
eeg-umlage und auch steuerlich
finanzieren können damals hat mir
ausgerechnet zehn milliarden hätte das
gekostet damals war aber eine andere
situation
man hatte nicht die bereitschaft auch in
der koalition damals nicht diese
finanzierung über steuern zu leisten
jetzt haben wir eine situation ins
rutschen vielfach angesprochen dass wir
eine menge an kosten belastungen haben
der verbraucher die preise sind nach
oben gegangen chance durch bewohner
bestimmte effekte die ich jetzt nicht im
einzelnen ausführen kann in der vorigen
räder nichts getan die in frage des
krieges eine enorme spekulation auf
verknappung spielt eine rolle bei den
preissteigerungen und jetzt ist in der
tat die zeit zu sagen okay wir
übernehmen kostenlasten die jetzt in der
eeg-umlage stecken und finanzieren sie
staatlicherseits davon profitieren
natürlich jetzt nicht die unternehmen
die sowieso schon entlastet sind sondern
davon profitieren die stromkunden und
stromkunden und das macht sich durch
auch bemerkbar es sind über die in einem
vier-personen-haushalt von 4000
kilowattstunden sind das alleine mit
diesen mit dieser maßnahme 133 euro das
ist in der summe mit vielen anderen
maßnahmen die wir noch beschlossen haben
einiges und es ist stück weit auch
einfach gerecht dass diese
fördermaßnahmen jetzt auch von der
allgemeinheit getragen werden insofern
ist richtig diese absenkung auf null
vorzunehmen ist es eine absenkung auf
null ist es keine abschaffung ist ein ab
60 in diesem sinne freue ich mich dass
wir das heute beschließen vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
an den könig ist die nächste rednerin in
der button von der cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben heute
im deutschen bundestag nun endlich die
gelegenheit die absenkung der
erneuerbaren energie umlage auf null zu
beschließen diese absenkung und damit
die entlaste und viele stromkunden in
unserem land haben wir als
unionsfraktion bereits zu jahresbeginn
gefordert denn die energiepreise
befanden sich bereits zum jahreswechsel
auf rekordniveau mit dem beginn des
russischen angriff krieges gegen die
ukraine der die energiepreise durch die
decke gehen ließ ist es nun erst recht
eine dringende und längst überfällige
entscheidung geworden
[Applaus]
unserem damaligen antrag hat die
regierung aber zunächst abgelehnt um den
vorschlag dann jetzt in der oster paket
aufzunehmen wir finden zwar einsicht ist
der erste weg zur besserung dass er
unterstützen wir sie natürlich heute bei
der senkung der eu die umlage lieber
spät als nie leider haben sie aber in
den ersten wochen des jahres viel zu
viel zeit verstreichen lassen ohne sich
um wirksame entlastung für private und
gewerbliche kunden zu kümmern
und wessen geistes kind ihre politik ist
zeigt sich im saldierung verbot dass sie
ins kleingedruckte ihres entwurfs
geschrieben haben die streichung der eeg
umlage muss danach eigens ausgewiesen
und darf nicht bürokratiearme verrechnet
werden wichtiger als die entlastung der
menschen ist ihnen offenbar ihre
angeblichen wohltaten in ein strahlendes
licht zu rücken und sie haben dabei
nicht einmal mehr hemmungen die
energieversorger für ihre
regierungsarbeit in die pflicht zu
nehmen es gibt also keinen grund sich
heute für diese senkung selbst auf die
schulter zu klopfen
zumal sie diese maßnahme aller
voraussicht nach auf gar nichts kostet
denn während viele verbraucher nicht
wissen wie sie die nächste stromrechnung
zahlen sollen ist das eeg konto gut
gefüllt hier können sie also einfach von
vorhandenen guthaben zerren ja die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage ist ein
erster richtiger schritt aber eben auch
nicht mehr als ein erster schritt
weitere müssen zügig folgen denn
vermutlich wird die absenkung bei
weiteren preissteigerungen bis ende des
jahres für den verbraucher leider
allenfalls ein nullsummenspiel
und wenn sie einmal ehrlich zu sich
selbst sind dann müssen sie doch zugeben
dass die seit beginn ihrer
regierungsübernahme mit ihrer politik
der energiepreisentwicklung nur
hinterherlaufen das haben wir beobachten
müssen bei ihrem nachgebesserten und
immer noch unzureichenden
heizkostenzuschuss und das haben wir
aktuell auch bei der posse um die
dämpfung der spritpreise für drei monate
gesehen
wir befinden uns aber in der größten
krise und zwar nachkriegsgeschichte und
die energiepolitik ist das feld auf dem
diese krise innenpolitisch am stärksten
sichtbar wird in dieser zeit brauchen
wir keine regierung die päckchen spürt
es recht brauchen wir keine
überschriften und ankündigungen mehr
sondern wir brauchen jetzt und hier eine
regierung mit einem plan die das problem
explodierender energiepreise strukturell
und mit weitblick angeht so weit hier
aus der debatte zur absenkung der eeg
umlage
morgen werden wir natürlich auch wieder
die plenardebatte für sie übertragen ab
8.45 sind wir da wieder hier live aus
dem deutschen bundestag unter anderem
mit dem jahresbericht 20 21 der
wehrbeauftragte hier bei phoenix geht es
jetzt weiter mit einem phoenix plus
stimmen des krieges und um 1830 versorgt
sie dann thomas bade mit allem wichtigen
von heute in der sendung der tag bleiben
sie bei phoenix